yeah hello into one this video
claymation last I light like martin
fool's under a no-strings III huh what
do i do against that I don't really have
a fantastic line ready I can I can I can
play this which is not very well known
but it can be irritating for white
players yeah Queen D for Queenie six
chicken like it's pretty decent
equalizing chance here it's a little bit
boring but it's something you can play
if you're happy with a draw I just down
yeah hey let's just play something
boring Queen Queen a form twin g4s
equalizing from luck already have that
in the tournament game
the fact that it's equal doesn't mean
that it must be a draw of course I can
still continue why would you want to
misplace your night I don't know ok
let's take and just developed I guess
maybe you want to play for Knight coming
to see five possible maybe I should
click we should be seven actually anyway
so what do I go b6 Bishop d7 or not I
think I do just want to have them have c
5 square covered ok it is it is
symmetrical and probably equal yes not
not much to do problem okay I need to be
a little bit cautious because I tend to
be it'll tend to be too relaxed if
things get simplified and then I bring
us get into trouble 96 looked very very
normal ish take special cheeks and that
should be okay and not not much in terms
of traps Bishop a six I don't know if I
wanted too bad if I go a six nights 7b
five I don't think I don't think this is
particularly dangerous nylon 6 7 has no
squares also
97 for bishop at six or so right this is
also possible you can also do that right
a form
wrong answer I just wanted to although
less than zero yeah I ever said it was
very exciting but maybe there's the hot
reversal they are looking for something
offbeat against the against III and yeah
this is not bad it looks a little bit
strange to play like that but I think
it's very difficult for y to get
something of course you cannot win with
black basically unless why this doing
something really stupid but yeah this is
on the line there should be three years
a bit more interesting here as it avoids
this immediate cringy form here i think
i am it's it's more or less clear that
black equalizers if anything it's a very
slight pool for Wyatt pursuits it's not
much but what actually interesting maybe
495 during the game I was thinking it
cannot be really good but ok maybe
bishop before check out the engine
indicates but I would be surprised if
there was ever anything going on here
check check nature's just very dry she
there was nothing nothing going on here
we which way down anywhere everything
yeah so it's an interesting of feed line
if you feel like you're happy with the
draw just one something totally equal
against the strong player then this is
not so bad I don't see anything
fantastic four white them ok guys thanks
for watching